[Music]
look at the headlines here now Jazeera
now we've got some breaking news from
the UK Chancellor quasi quateng has
resigned less than six weeks into the
job he was asked to step aside by the
Prime Minister let's go straight to
Jonah Ali's outside number 10 Downing
Street what kind of uh political
earthquake is uh is that resignation
sending through
Each Other Well Sammy just give me a
second to turn off my phone if you don't
mind
uh remember just 24 hours ago quasi
quateng was in Washington at a meeting
of the international uh monetary fund
its annual meeting he gave an interview
there he was asked whether there was
going to be a u-turn on the budget
whether his job was in trouble he said
there is no change of thinking on the
budget and I'm going nowhere he said he
would proceed with plans to produce a
midterm budget statement on the 31st of
October at which he would try to car
markets by explaining exactly how these
tens of billions of dollars in tax
giveaways tax cuts were going to be paid
for in terms of a growth plan involving
uh fleshed out so-called supply side
reforms well it turned out he was
quickly on his way home after all got
here about an hour hour and a half ago
the news swiftly emerged that very much
indeed had changed particularly for
quasi quateng himself he'd been sacked
in point of act he put out a statement
saying this that he was asked to stand
aside you've asked me to stand aside he
said to the Prime Minister and I have
accepted he noted though that her visit
of optimism growth and change was right
that the status quo of high taxes and
low growth had to change and indeed he
said it would still have to change this
trust will give a press conference in
about half an hour's time now where she
will note changes of her own to that
budget plan and try to to calm the
markets in the hope that the sacking of
her Chancellor will allow a reset for
her deeply damaged Administration just
over a month since she took office all
right thanks so much Shona halver so the
key is
ordered his official